hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and I'm Jory Caron and this is Tamra's
never seen I hadn't seen it either
today we're watching Trainspotting right
now mm-hmm
you've not seen this ever we went
through a couple of things and you had
seen them all so this was the one we
landed on and we're expecting trains and
spotting and spotting great
I said Trainspotting predictions go
Tamra's never seen with a hashtag ever
[Music]
there were no trains there is no
spotting the movie felt long
we checked the time right at the end and
it felt so much longer than an hour and
a half yeah it's amazing how depressing
things congested if I didn't bag those
chips I was on Amazon sadness by looking
at model trains it was long and sad just
like you McGregor's dick oh I never
thought I would see him naked but
transponding there you go there you go
if you want to see a bunch of actors
dicks I do often say you always see
women's breasts but you never see guys
penises sorry I'm spotting I think some
of the cinematography was cool I really
liked the shot where he takes the hit
many floats into the ground that was
neat uh really weird shots like him
going into the toilet was so on yeah
yeah like I want to know if that was
like a real thing or was done in post
and if so who was the lucky person who
got to build the disgusting restroom
toilet that you could actually crawl in
mm-hmm like cuz that's a job that I want
you just opened up on Craigslist like
now now where anywhere except in the
toilet in this bathroom but that was not
the only time we saw shit everywhere oh
yeah I recognize him from from Wonder
Woman I recognize the guy who didn't do
drugs that just killed people
he was I know a lot of stuff a lot of
stuff I love you the guy who never did
hair wind
but then didn't died he was from the
show Rome but you know maybe a little
biased I'm gonna say I don't know how
Trainspotting for people like us who
haven't seen it I don't know how it's
gonna really be received and in like a
in like this day and age about a little
dated pacing is always different like
movies nowadays are paced it's so much
faster than 20 years and this is like a
is 21 years ago new 1996 I think yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah this one was old
enough to drink
damn shouldn't still shouldn't do heroin
but drink now
English oppression they have to drink
right away I loved when he went off on
Scottish people that was really funny
there were funny moments I guess but it
was just shrouded in sadness I really I
was expecting there to be there was a
story obviously but but I was expecting
it to be more about there what do you
think my story was my had you said story
but I heard the moral of like the story
and it was like I think the moral of the
story is don't do her story get a belly
shirt because that was a great look yeah
I heard there's a transporting to the
whole time I was thinking what why like
what else is there but no I imagine that
they find him wherever he went because
he stole of all their money at the end I
imagine he's they're all gonna find him
and try to get the money back
what if it's transferring to is just a
love story of him and
because he doesn't go back to Diane when
he's trying to like sell real estate
yeah she's writing him he seems to be
okay with her writing him but he was
before he was like me and then suddenly
it's like Naz is cool now you're good
so maybe Trainspotting too it's just the
love story of Jim and Diane I hope she's
in it at least well if it's a love story
of Kevin Diane I mean I don't know it
got good reviews and people love this
film I was so what did you what did you
take away from the film like what did
you did you like it did you know I mean
the same honestly I mean I'm glad I
watched it I guess hmm no no even then
no this is a film I would have put on if
I was alone if you guys were here I
would have put it on and I would have
shut it off
yeah I wouldn't finish it I don't have
you ever seen requiem for a dream that
movie makes me not want to do heroin
more than this movie as an anti-drug
requiem for a dream I think is a
stronger hitting yes well I mean at
least the last half the first half it's
like drugs are sweet this movie there's
never a point where it's like drugs are
sweet no these people are messes why did
they name it transpose
I have knows that a drug reference work
were there even trains in there was one
remember like Scottish Rite now I just
bought a bag of new needles I'm a
diabetic and it opened in my bag so my
bag is just full of loose needles and
that is tariffs I'm getting into Wizard
World yesterday they had to search and
you're like no no no okay I guess the
baby scene was really sad in that her
reaction was really sad to it but the
baby itself was sad but just more just
very creepy like looking like a zombie
like hmm how long was it there
I get the sense that it was there for
like two weeks
yeah well in that sense it's like really
like heroin is so good you will forget
about your baby for truly two weeks yeah
pros and cons I mean I'm glad you
McGregor turned himself around for his
career later on and then like really
betrayed all of his friends just really
stole four thousand dollars from each
one of his friends but his friends were
kind of dicks the other woman so he
basically screwed over his friends for
like thirty two thousand dollars yeah I
would do that yeah it's good to know
you're staying at my home right now yeah
yeah guys are giving me chips so like I
probably won't do it immediately
didn't you only come with one bag and
I'll have two and it will be full of the
rest of the chips the tape and what else
what would you take I'd take a couple of
the nectar or Soylent ones just Jesse
you would be like well it's not all bad
you know what you know you did get rid
of that for us he's a rascal but deep
down a good guy but a good guy so you
got rid of that nectar shit you're gonna
spot some trains dadada I don't know no
and no there were not trained no doors
one train they'll find you and McGregor
strangely attractive in a disgusting way
I was strangely curious about his belly
shirt you yeah yeah
so maybe just in that scene oh yeah okay
the zombie baby will be unexpected and
you'll never forget it even if you want
to the hole crawling on the ceiling
thing was too
I googled areas like I don't know about
the not forgetting it though I think I
will forget this movie in a day
completely yeah it did not leave any
lasting imprint on me at all you will
scream oh god no at least twice she will
scream oh god no zero time sorry to
break it to you but that happens zero
times I think we went into it with the
wrong mindset what mindset should we
have gone into it I think if I would
have known more what the tone was gonna
be in the end that it was gonna be like
an honest story I mean we were all
dressed up like conductors with hats
like we already had a tray I think
people are more affected by this than we
were yeah put me you'll be thinking the
whole time
drugs are bad okay you're going this far
out now is just wait not just not
recommend the movie but tell people not
to watch don't watch this film no I
don't know I am so curious as to why
people love this film that's why I'm
saying I think we went into it with it
the wrong heads I mean it came out with
a sequel so people must love it yeah why
yes I'll try my worst Scottish or best
Scottish accent if you try you have to
go for it Oh sick boy is sick sick boys
seriously lacking in moral fiber sick
boy is seriously lacking in moral fiber
nope I don't know no no sick boy is
seriously wahine moral fly by yeah that
was good that was probably terrible but
but I was thinking just assume that
there's a whole bunch of cotton in your
mouth yeah oh you have to flip your hair
that's the thing that I do
thank you all right see you next week
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you